(soft music)
- Behind me you see a collection of
spectacular blown-glass vases
by the New York decorator designer
stain glass artist Louis Comfort Tiffany.
I want to focus in particular
on the most spectacular of
this group in the center,
this blue iridescent glass of 1913.
That really marks the high point
of what was an intensive expression
of modern materials and forms.
The glass is called favrile.
It exploits the iridescent, natural,
and accidental beauties of blown-glass
in this form which drew its inspiration
from a "Jack In The Pulpit" flower.
I mean it scares me every time
I look at this object.
It's so fragile and
attenuated. It's (form).
What I love about this glass
is the way it combines ancient and modern.
Tiffany was inspired by ancient,
Roman, and (terrain) glass,
which has this iridescent
finish when it was dug up.
At the same time, he wanted to create
these startling modern objects.
People were blown away when they were
exhibited at the Colombian Worlds Fair
and in the Paris 1900 exhibition.
What you see in this blue vase of 1913
is almost like the last gasp,
and the combination of this intensive
expiration of form and technique
for which Tiffany became
internationally famed.